how's it going bro this is pine welcome
to five that's ten five weird stuff
online the show finally has a name how
about that amazing
let's begin by getting in the right
outfit I found a knife and online that I
feel like I would look pretty snazzy in
or I'm changing or all blah
oh my god I'm not even wearing it
correctly
yes I'm Fiona from frozen is that right
you look like a [ __ ] [ __ ] don't
worry I have an outfit for you too ah
don't bite me woman no no no step step
step
I have an outfit for you too even though
you don't deserve it
[ __ ] crazy I need you to work with me
here yeah
a dog wait how the [ __ ] is this gonna
work
I never seen a dog this crazy I never
seen a dog disgrace you are basically a
[ __ ] right now you're a [ __ ]
where are the outfit all right all right
can we just enjoy herself
okay well he has he's supposed to have
TVs but they are kind of I mean I have
better titties in you what
next item I ask you brothers on Twitter
for suggestions and this is probably one
of the most suggested ones I don't
understand why but we're gonna check out
is an electronic yodeling pickle here it
is I'm prepared to be amazed next item
we have camel balls it's supposed to be
extra sour so let's try it oh god it
really looks like camel balls
how bad can it be
huh I'm free again ha ha
a lot of camel balls just like your long
balls in general shut up shut up
final item Brea's it's it's kind of
weird a lot of you bros suggested this
one it's a unicorn meat it says here we
guarantee that the unicorns in care are
treated with utmost love and respect
until they go over the double rainbow
bridge so I don't know if this is real
it says contains magic hundred percent
giggles 100% happiness hundred percent
superglue thousand percent it says this
is not actual food and don't eat it but
I feel like we should try it anyway
because there's definitely something
inside Oh smells ahh get again
thanks pretty good I don't feel
different if like nothing changed
well it's the point of the meet
I write brace I'm gonna go and go do
unicorn things now but if you enjoyed
this video hit that like button and let
me know if you want more and recommend
me some more weird [ __ ] and I'll check
it out if you're a unicorn bro like me
then unicorn your your screen right now
with me let's do it is bro unicorn fish
I missed damnit that's awkward again bro
unicorn fist there it is I like her the
boobs are like granny tits